perhaps drifting into the philosophical
uh let me ask about the Big Bang as we
kind of encroach onto it so your work is
kind of taking steps back through time
in a weird way
do you think we'll get to deeper and
deeper understand
the really really early days of the Big
Bang
and um the philosophical question do you
think we'll be able to understand what
was before the Big Bang
or why the Big Bang happened you think
about that stuff
um not with stars For Better or For
Worse because you know Stars only probe
the time when they were formed and the
Big Bang is surely before then I mean I
I often talk to my students about the
difference between math and physics
um let me give you an example um we
talked earlier about 80 1523 and you
know I I was happy to to share with you
that I measure thorium and uranium but I
actually didn't quite close that Loop so
we we did this to try to attempt to
calculate an age for these Stars right
um but they rely on us knowing how the r
process works how these elements are
created where it happens and then how
those elements get dispersed into the
gas and end up in the next Generation
store so quite a few question marks so
that's how we got to the age of 13.2
billion years this is probably not
accurate but this is the best
calculation we could do
um and uh the reason why I'm bringing
this up is that that was actually the
average of multiple
um Elemental ratios that each gave a
certain age and then we average that
because For Better or For Worse this is
the best we can do so some of these
numbers said oh this star is 15 billion
years old and then others said oh this
is 10 billion years old and so I often
use that in my class to say like
what's the good news and what's the bad
news here some ratio said 15 something
10 right is 15 correct
and then I asked to ask them and some
people will say something
and so the the thing here is that it's
an absolutely correct calculation given
the mathematical and physical model that
we constructed but does it make sense no
it doesn't if we believe the universe is
13.8 billion years old
15 is is ridiculous yet it is correct
isn't that interesting correct from a
mathematics perspective it is not
incorrect because this is what I
calculated nobody made a mistake now we
can question whether that's a good model
but that's that's a separate issue so
you're saying physicists are much closer
to truth than mathematicians well it
depends
no right so yeah what our job as
physicist is is to take the mathematical
model calculate our numbers and then ask
the question does this make sense right
now
in the case of 15 it doesn't but we took
the average anyway because
that was the the best we could do right
so all right let's put that aside let's
apply the same sort of thinking to the
Big Bang right math can tell us things
that we as physicists cannot grasp
because it doesn't make sense to us now
in the case of the big band that's big
bang that's a special case because we
don't actually know what's supposed to
make sense yeah and this is where things
get interesting but this is where math
will ultimately be the winner because we
can no longer say this makes sense or
this doesn't make sense because the
physics is broken down but math breaks
down too in the singularity of things
well or no depending on who you ask okay
sure sure this is this is the current
question right how far how much further
can we push math let's say to the front
of the Big Bang if there is such a thing
um what's the front in the back what's
the front before the Big Bang the front
okay
so how far can we let the math go before
that stops to make sense right and I
don't know what the answer is to that
but it's it's really cool that because
math doesn't have is not limited by of
our physical nature
it can probably go a little bit further
than the physics yeah right and math can
go into uh
more Dimensions than four dimensions
comfortably and it's it's judgment free
because it just calculates things on its
own whereas as physicists we are so
judgmental yeah this makes sense this
doesn't make sense right it doesn't get
any worse it's such a beautiful dance
it's such a uh it's so amazing that
through this dance you can explore the
origins of the universe
like
doesn't the Big Bang just blow your mind
that this thing is just starting from a
point
yeah and now we're here yeah yeah yeah
hydrogen and helium and then all the
stuff you're studying
I mean this this this evolution of
chemistry created
humans
and we're here talking
and there's a lot more to the story
it's amazing yeah yeah yeah uh
and this kind of March that you're doing
is observing data
and is there
foreign
you're looking at old light on old data
but only a few thousand years right just
a few thousand that's that's the
difference between me and my jwst
colleagues yes their objects that light
has traveled 13 billion years or
whatever it was to us and they're
observing that now my light has only
traveled a few thousand years it's it's
nothing so whatever You observe now is
likely still going on yes these stars
are alive and kicking and having a blast
Thousand Years
just a few thousand years that all it
takes if we can travel close to the
speed of light
yeah maybe we can reach out there
we wouldn't have any planets around
those tasks though so that's is that a
definitive intuition well what a
planet's made of elements right to take
the Earth as all Heavy elements right
the universe needed to reach a certain
stage first to have produced enough of
all these elements to actually make a
planet so on average you go so okay
right so that took quite a few billion
years so they're not going to have a
mechanism for forming planets you could
have visitors probably but the the the
kinematics of that are weird are
unlikely yeah I would say so
so they're interesting in that they
reveal the early chemical evolution of
the universe yes not that they're uh
they could be good vacation spots but
not well there's not like a warm
it's just not no no Planet Islands to to
go to to chill